how scum rose my spear to Pat welcome to
doorways all right we're gonna play on
the oculus that means I'm gonna probably
get a heart attack or some [ __ ]
see you at the hospital oh god I can't
see anything this poor Swedish man is
about to embark on a journey for all his
bro-chachos and it crashed well what are
you gonna do ah too bad I guess we don't
have to play that hey it's like l2 not
changed resolution so that I can France
that [ __ ] alright here we go here we go
here we go so sexy well what're you
gonna do I'm leaving this hell man it's
what I asked myself when I go to the
toilet every day oh oh we're playing
that's a Muzzin and by amazing I mean
[ __ ] we're dead there we go oh god I
feel a little motion sickness crawling
up on me bruh ChaCha's that is not a
good thing no it's not alright I'll see
I'll try and power through it I'm a man
and my name is Sam why would I lie about
something like that it's not like you
bros would I buy that [ __ ] doorway C on
the world we're going to the underworld
brochacho
I never been a big fan of the underworld
the upper world yes but just underworld
in general makes me feel like I'm
crawling into somebody deep dark hole
help me [ __ ] what is this
what Oh again am I gonna go in that oh
my god those are the biggest not serious
I've ever seen
oh god this is [ __ ] creepy man I am
not okay with this and that is not
racist we're inside this giant man's
mouth duh I mean though this is kind of
cozy I quite like it hey hello hello
anything chip chap cheerio going on here
chip chap on this area bro ho I run like
six words in one sentence where's my
rapper license [ __ ] what is this is all
empty instant hello we are going to a
party and the party is me dying I think
so when you see the mattress of blood I
should be in a musical or some [ __ ] it's
called watch boots die slowly I guess
that's my youtube channel technically
actually I'll think about it
hello everything's good in there dies
first huh okey how convenient
hello key you float over there thank you
very much now let's find if there's a
key there's a hole in it there's a hole
that I'm there if you know what I'm
saying
oh oh there it is okay well that that
wasn't too difficult all right let's see
here ah there you are
just where put you thank you very much
thank you very much indeed
hello had a demon sword [ __ ] like that
don't wanna [ __ ] God [ __ ] me Oh God
I can find another man in a minute
medified here you be here
alright I'll guess we're going in here
who's crying I'm not okay with crying
women use this place but is this class
yes listen to him vatos ass class hello
Oh God crying girls man they freak my
why is it so weird you'd think it'd be
weird with the crying man but new
perhaps it's in here oh god no no no
what does that sound what is that sound
no no no I can't I can't I can't Steve
oh god there's nothing out there is it
okay okay okay okay
hey where are we going papa
Oh what is this place this is so weird
and not the good kind of we're like oh
you're so weird that's a cow no it's
like god damn it I wanted oh god oh god
it's so dark no I can't no I can't oh oh
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ on here ah
lights just speaks as it wills and
mattresses are filled with blood and I'm
really [ __ ] scared okay this is not
the funny kind of scared like haha look
how scary is this is I'm Lilly sharing
my [ __ ] pants huh oh god shut up shut
up Mayo ah okay
okay we're good very good whoa what is
this oh god I didn't see this before oh
[ __ ] it's one of these huh hi how's
everyone doin what are you what is that
seriously what is what the [ __ ] is that
that is not the type of thing that I put
in my collection Oh God okay we got what
we have the real look now let's just get
out get out get out get out get out of
my head and play to my arms instead I
don't I know don't know what it is but I
need your 1d that's not the lurks what
is this now oh god no no no no no no no
no no no no that's out I'm gonna go I'm
going I don't care what the [ __ ] you're
doing
oh god okay all right this place smells
and I got this good cheat Gucci shoes
that I'm gonna have to at least polish
them up proper good after this oh oh god
oh god oh no okay
where do I go oh well there's only this
way actually what do I do with its
really thing it's like they don't think
I don't have a life or some [ __ ]
actually I think they know I don't have
a life
hello what's this now Wow
well that went better than expected I am
sweating and dripping it like I am
literally taking a bath right now
I don't know how to explain this
purchase but I'm glad you're with me
okay hey what beat the [ __ ] man don't do
that
I don't even know what's going on sniff
dog just came and said hi like what's up
with that this is all some kind of sick
joke isn't it I knew it
one three zero five I got you now
[ __ ]
one three zero five whoa
hey it's about in the USA ASAE it's this
open now no well what did i do then
Mamma Mia what did I do
what says is that what the [ __ ] that I
do the [ __ ] did I do mate oh it opened
[ __ ] me I'm stupid I've completed the
amputation of his arms and legs he is a
pain killed it was necessary this time
the most practical solution will be
removing his tongue why what do you know
not everyone is meant to be a singer are
they Justin Bieber Miley Cyrus it all
applies but they don't listen they never
listen sometimes you have to make them
listen I'm winking at you bros right now
just so you know my facial expression in
case there's some confusion this is me
winking all right in you go set and a
little twisted to it you wait we did a
brat high-five I don't know where you
are
I could be high-fiving like a demon
who's right there right and it's like
[ __ ] with me Oh God that way I don't
want to high-five any demons oh I told
you I told you I don't want to I told
you I didn't want to huh hello I know
it's nu T tell clearly Kongo let me see
you move like you come to rhumble Umbria
ah stay away from him
my nipples are exploding they're
exploding I think there's milk Oh God
he's not very nice is it
he's not very nice is he he's not a very
nice man he has a very nice horse but
that does not make it a very nice man I
keep telling you Carolyn it's not a very
nice man
no God is coming he's coming
Wow hey hey hey gotta take a little
break here yes yes I think it's good
time good time team effort very good
team effort today Bruce very good yeah
like this video and subscribe in the
brofist